bonjour bienvenue à tous c'est mission
spéciale cette semaine petite
tremblement de terre dans l'espace
européen depuis lundi Alexis cipras
leader est devenu le nouveau Premier
ministre grec la campagne anti-austérité
a donc porté ses fruits avec 149 sièges
sur 300 la victoire est écrasante nous
nous rendrons également à quelques
centaines de kilomètres d'Athènes où les
producteurs de fruits et légumes
jusque-là épargnés par la crise souffre
désormais de l'embargorus un embargo
décidé par Moscou suite aux sanctions
européennes et à la guerre en Ukraine
dans un contexte économique déjà
difficile les producteurs attendent
beaucoup de l'Union européenne mais
également de leur nouveau gouvernement
alors Alexis cyprras peut-il
révolutionner l'Europe c'est la question
de la semaine et à les poser par Simon
barbarie
c'est le nouvel homme fort de la Grèce
Alexis cipras le nouveau Premier
ministre éliteur de Syriza le parti de
la gauche radicale envoie un message
clair à l'Europe non à la politique
d'austérité 36% des suffrages 149
députés sur 300 à l'issue de ses
élections législatives anticipées si
Risa froule la majorité absolue et
redonne espoir à la gauche de la gauche
européenne comme en Espagne où le parti
podemos est au coude à coude dans les
sondages avec le Parti populaire de
droite côté dirigeant européen David
Cameron s'inquiète son tweet voit en
l'élection grecque le renforcement de
l'instabilité économique de l'Europe et
si François Hollande adresse et
félicitations et invite le nouveau
leader grec à Paris Angela Merkel par la
voix de son porte-parole rappelle la
Grèce à ses obligations tout comme le
président de l'euro groupe et bien sûr
être membre de la zone euro signifie
également que vous vous conformiez avec
tout ce qui était convenu bien sûr cette
base nous sommes prêts à travailler avec
eux la banque cent rale européenne à
d'ores et déjà annoncé qu'il n'y aurait
pas de réduction mais un échelonnement
de la dette grecque une dette de 320
milliards d'euros tout de même soit 177%
du PIB la tâche s'annonce donc rue de
pour Alexis cipras dont le programme
ambitieux s'élève après de 12 milliards
d'euros alors malgré tous ces obstacles
Alexis de Cypress peut-il ouvrir une
nouvelle politique en Europe
alors est-ce qu'on peut attendre Alexis
de cypras qu'il révolutionne l'Union
européenne c'est la question que je vais
poser à mes invités ingress le bonjour
vous êtes député allemande du Parti
conservateur du groupe PPE ici au sein
de ce Parlement traversa vous êtes
espagnol membre du groupe libéral et
démocrates et Guillaume balaise vous
êtes au Parti socialiste français alors
on pourrait dire membre plutôt de l'aile
gauche du Parti socialiste alors
ingression je me tourne vers vous est-ce
que vous attendez vous d'alexit sipraz
qui les révolutionne l'Union européenne
pas du tout pas du tout je me soucie
comment va-t-on faire avec le peuple
graisse qui a voté on respecte ce vote
mais ce vote est basé sur temps de
promesses de mensonges même et aussi des
attentes fausses c'est pour ça qu'il
faut maintenant tout faire pour calmer
un peu le jeu en Grèce Guillaume mallès
est-ce qu'ils doivent respecter les
accords c'est pas une révolution mais ça
indique une évolution et on voit bien
que c'est pas le seul signe la nouvelle
politique de la Banque centrale
européenne qui a annoncé la semaine
dernière
la commission européenne qui annonce la
flexibilité budgétaire pour les états la
victoire de cipras en Grèce montre
qu'aujourd'hui il faut réorienter les
politiques de l'Union européenne
pourquoi parce que celles qu'on a mise
en place ensemble et c'est pas plus les
Allemands que les autres ne fonctionnent
pas et j'aimerais juste ajouter une
chose moi je comprends les Allemands
quand ils disent il y a des choses qu'on
était signé il faut il faut les
respecter c'est logique et on peut pas
en vouloir aujourd'hui l'Allemagne de
dire ça mais il faut que l'Allemagne
comprenne que ce qui a été signé est
idiot et je prends l'exemple de la Grèce
jamais cette cette dette ne sera
intégralement remboursée il vaut mieux
passer un bon accord pour qu'il ait la
reconstruction d'un état grec où il y a
de la fiscalité où il y a un cadastre et
un allègement de la dette je pense que
l'Allemagne y compris il y a intérêt
vous pouvez comprendre qu'à partir du
moment où on a prêté 319 milliards
d'euros dont 141 milliards par le Fonds
européen de stabilité financière et
l'équivalent de 53 milliards de près
bilatéraux rentrés européens on est
quand même en droit d'exiger à un moment
c'est quand même vos impôts les miens
ceux des des citoyens européens de toute
façon la Grèce mettrait les calculs ont
été faits plus d'une centaine d'années
aujourd'hui pour ce remboursement là on
a su faire dans le passé par ailleurs
des politiques intelligentes il ne
s'agit pas de dire que la Grèce ne doit
pas rembourser rien du tout que toute la
dette est illégitime ça c'est un
discours absurde mais qu'on est une
politique intelligente et qu'on arrive à
trouver un accord intelligent qui aille
à tout le monde et encore une fois qu'il
fasse que la graisse fasse les vrais
réformes qu'elle devrait faire notamment
d'avoir un état performant avec une
vraie fiscalité où tout le monde paie et
pas simplement j'allais dire les les
plus pauvres d'entre eux je crois que ça
serait extrêmement efficace et donc un
accord gagnant-gagnant à trouver
aujourd'hui je crois justement sur cette
question Guillaume balaise me dit qu'il
y a un accord gagnant-gagnant à trouver
est-ce que vous êtes d'accord là-dessus
on connaît la situation de l'Espagne
est-ce que le cas grec si jamais il y a
une un reichlonement ou un effacement
partiel de la dette qui est déjà arrivé
par ailleurs est-ce que ça pourrait
faire jurisprudence pour l'Espagne non
absolument différents c'est la
Méditerranée que c'est quelque chose
c'est comment
une toute petite partie de l'économie
européenne d'abord il faut dire que les
problèmes que les Grecs sont en train de
souffre c'est des problèmes que c'est
pas sont pas arrivés de nous même comme
nous les Espagnols en train de souffrir
notre propre problème que cela
conséquence de une manque des politiques
je veux dire avec un minimum de logique
et des parties populaires et des parties
socialistes c'est les mêmes choses qui
s'est passé en Grèce dit passe à encore
avec plus de profondeur en Grèce ils
sont souffert un véritable dynastie des
carameli c'est pas pendréo
soit du sans socialisme mais c'est une
socialisme et monarchique
chie il faut arrêter avec cette
oligarchie depuis toujours
justement sur cette question on a vu que
même le FMI il y a déjà quelques années
il y a deux ou trois ans avait dit que
on avait été trop loin dans l'austérité
en Grèce est-ce que vous comprenez que
il faille revenir un type un petit peu
sur ces politiques et est-ce qu'il
comment rétablir une forme de croissance
qui puisse permettre aux grec et aux
autres pays du sud de l'Europe notamment
je pense à l'Espagne je pense au
Portugal je pense à l'Italie à la France
de renouer un petit peu avec la
croissance je crois qu'il y a pas de
recette miracle il faut être franc la
Grèce a plus de problèmes de
surendettement elle a beaucoup de
problèmes d'être en état d'avoir une
administration qui marche d'avoir une
économie qui digne du nom économie qui
est la Grèce a eu droit à beaucoup
d'argent de la part de l'Union
européenne et si on regarde par exemple
le fond de développement rural la Grèce
est la plus mauvaise en prenant en
absorbant ces fonds là c'est à dire ce
n'est pas qu'une question du manque
d'argent est là à sans pratiquement pour
la Grèce ils auraient pu faire quelque
chose mais ils sont pas capables la
Commission européenne y est allée avec
le casque force pour faire les projets
c'est à dire ils ont complètement
politique cette prise et c'est la classe
politique grecque qui n'est pas capable
je crois qu'on s'est fondamentalement
trop trompé sur l'état de la Grèce mais
on a fermé les yeux et maintenant on va
payer le prix de ce fait qu'on a fermé
les yeux c'est ça le problème on a fermé
les yeux
madame c'est le faux chemin parce que ça
va encourager la situation qu'on laisse
toute telle qu'elle moi je comprends vos
peurs mais je salue je salue la victoire
de cerisa un seul point c'est que
maintenant ils vont s'attaquer j'espère
au moins qu'ils tiennent parole aux
riches grecques pour qu'il paye les
taxes aux armateurs et à l'église
orthodoxe par exemple également tout le
monde doit payer les taxes ça c'est
clair chez nous les églises payent pas
en Allemagne et les églises payent pas
non plus les taxes en Allemagne
et moi je comprends vos peurs mais je
voudrais vous dire plusieurs choses la
première tout d'abord c'est que nous
avons été complice mais nous avons été
complice parce que nous aussi nous avons
aidé à maquiller les contes de la Grèce
on les a maquillés même deux fois on les
a maquillés pour qu'ils rentrent dans
l'euro et après on les a maquillés pour
leur imposer un surplace d'austérité
mais je mets tout le monde dans le
bateau et je suis d'accord sur je veux
dire ce qui s'est passé en date sur les
parties mais attendez et c'est pour ça
qu'il fallait pas soutenir Samara madame
pendant le pendant les dernières années
évidemment parce que il représentait
avec Papa Briou et j'en suis d'accord
toute cette classe politique grecque qui
n'a justement pas fait les réformes et
donc vous devriez au contraire vous
devriez au contraire vous dire Madame
que c'est une chance aujourd'hui d'avoir
un parti sur lequel j'adhère pas à tout
hein je veux dire moi je connais pas
plus que ça monsieur cipras mais
simplement qui dit et j'ai entendu le
futur ministre de l'économie de le dire
on va remettre un état cohérent debout
si déjà ils arrivent à faire ça alors
après les accords qui sont passés
peuvent être respectés mais si vous vous
n'y croyez pas dans la solution c'est
faire sortir la graisse de l'euro
maintenant
je vous ai jamais vu travailler sur ce
chantier moi j'y travaille depuis 10 ans
européens
est-ce que faut s'attendre à une sortie
de la graisse de l'euro si jamais tout
ça ne fonctionne pas
même l'Espagne et même tout pays
d'Europe dehors les euros c'est les
desserts de Sahara 6 c'est la mort alors
on doit toujours trouver des ressources
au marché et les marchés c'est les
rouleaux et la garantie d'euros m'a dit
pense que Canon parle de la Grèce on
tente de voir la Grèce de l'extérieur
c'est-à-dire c'est un problème européen
on le regarde comme français comme
aliment comme italiens vivaient le
regarder comme grec alors ça c'est le
premier
protagonistes c'est le vrai que même
lui-même alors
en Grèce le pigments des impôts
c'est-à-dire les fraudes fiscales
c'était le sport national
personne n'est payé des impôts alors
c'est un état qui s'est passé sur les
gaspillage et sur le clientélisme alors
à ce niveau quand esprit arrive il pense
que ça c'est quand même une tremblement
de terre Sétif et ça c'est dire c'est
fini
toute cette fête fou
il y a des propositions qui sont
absolument
fantasieuses c'est-à-dire on va pas
payer la dette on va aller chez le nez
la dette ça dépend des créditaires alors
on verra qu'est-ce que ça passe alors
justement sur cette réalité il y a il y
a eu un espèce d'appel d'air depuis la
victoire de Syriza en Grèce qui a ouvert
d'autres horizons notamment en Espagne
où le parti podémosquets présent ici au
sein de ce Parlement européen c'est un
petit peu senti poussé des ailes avant
les élections de la fin de l'année 2015
je voudrais qu'on écoute son leader
nous pensons que c'est une bonne
nouvelle pour le sud de l'Europe et que
ça ouvre une nouvelle idée de l'Europe
basée sur la souveraineté du peuple une
souveraineté nationale et populaire
la Grèce a enfin un dirigeant grec et
non un délégué d'Angela Merkel pas un
président détaché aux affaires grecques
pour l'Allemagne mais un dirigeant
patriote
et qui va évidemment remplir ses
obligations internationales
on a vu
au satandre au même phénomène en Espagne
dans quelques mois non il n'y a rien à
voir c'est à dire parfois les
journalistes trouvent les titres pour
remettre la première ligne ça c'est très
intéressant c'est à dire ni la Grèce
l'Espagne ni l'Espagne et c'est l'Italie
ni la France c'est l'Hollande il y a pas
de lien entre des situations
alors l'estime beaucoup il y a sur ce
que je pense que c'est très important
plus important que notre partie sont
partis les parties socialiste on est
parti populaire aujourd'hui on est dans
une société d'exclusion
signifie que la concentration des
richesse dans les parties la plus hautes
de la société signifie pas seulement
l'élimination des classes moyennes mal
élimination c'est-à-dire laisser presque
dit 12% même peut-être plus en Espagne
dehors toute participation à la société
ça risque le plus important parce qu'il
faut que vraiment on laisse tomber notre
portagonisme en pensant que nous les
politiciens on est vraiment c'est à dire
les grands acteurs les grands acteurs
c'est la société on parle jamais de la
société on part de nous-mêmes
Guillaume Balas sur cette question
est-ce que vous pensez qu'il peut y
avoir un front comme ça des forces de
gauche au sein l'Union européenne on
s'attendait avec l'accession pouvoir de
ma théorenzi ce qui est aussi pareil une
révolution finalement c'est pas passé
grand chose il y a deux choses la
première chose moi je suis assez
d'accord sur le fait de raisonner je
vais dire classiquement sur le fait
alliance de partie qui va faire bouger
etc et pas suffisant et on voit bien que
aujourd'hui ce qui est en train
d'émerger c'est quoi c'est la volonté de
démocratie au sens pure du terme c'est à
dire le pouvoir du peuple et on peut
plus rester avec des appareils
politiques qui semblent en effet je vais
dire de plus en plus contestable dans la
manière de faire après au niveau
européen moi je pense que la France
malheureusement une responsabilité dans
le fait qu'il ce que vous et ce que vous
avez décrit c'est pas vraiment créé je
pense que matte nos affaires l'appel du
pied je pense qu'après 2012 et la
victoire de François Hollande on aurait
pu aller plus loin dans la discussion
dans la rediscution au niveau européen
de ce qui avait été établi et qui ne
fonctionne pas qui ne fonctionne pas
depuis 2008 et que on a un peu loupé le
coche deux points de vue là la victoire
de Cypress j'allais dire et aussi la
nouvelle politique de la BCE et aussi la
Commission européenne qui commence à
bouger et le FMI qui commence à dire que
l'austérité en Europe ça suffit tous ces
signaux-là montrent qu'il faut
rediscuter en Europe et je pense que
François Hollande là a une carte à jouer
maintenant justement une graisse le sur
cette question quand vous voyez que il y
a une volonté donc en Italie en Espagne
en Grèce en France avec l'arrivée de
François Hollande mais il y a déjà
quelques années est-ce que l'Allemagne
ne risque pas et Angela Merkel a priori
de se retrouver isolé vous savez la
question n'est pas d'isole être isolé ou
pas je suis étonné on a des accords et
nous on a pris des garanties sur la base
de ces accords là sur la base des
promesses d'être fiables les accords là
et maintenant je peux pas dire voilà
maintenant on a changé de d'opinion on a
changé d'avis nous on peut pas changer
d'avis quand on traverse une fleuve et
on est au milieu on est au milieu et je
dois vous dire que les résultats
européens que vous les décrivez elles
sont peut-être pas suffisamment c'est
vrai mais je dois vous dire que vous
dites n'est pas vrai sur le passé vous
savez mon problème c'est que il y a des
bases légales pour tout où on a pris on
a pris des galeries
importantes le gouvernement allemand est
lié par ses garanties par cette base
légale elle peut pas en sortir
le droit c'est quand ça vous arrange je
trouve ça très irresponsable que vous
faites que vous faites semblant comme si
on change ça très facilement il faut
rediscuter c'est la politique madame
c'est pas le droit qui gouverne comme ça
c'est la politique c'est le peuple fin
février l'heure de vérité c'est la
dernière tranche de deuxième paquet pour
être pour la graisse
vous êtes un responsable politique
s'il vous plaît on ne trouve toujours
cette genre de match de tennis entre les
socialistes et les populaires c'est pour
ça que vous êtes là en tant que libéral
démocratie oublier c'est la réalité
c'est-à-dire on n'est pas les gardiens
de la vérité bien sûr alors qu'est-ce
qui va être c'est une situation dans
lequel c'est vrai que les Grecs ils
seront que c'est la seule alternatif
pour que les paiements c'est impossible
on est des responsables de la situation
même pourquoi on a tu as raison on a
accepté toute cette viande de mensonges
et les Grecs sont aussi responsables
alors je dis que Siri ça va confronté la
réalité il y a une autre problématique à
laquelle va être confronté dans quelques
temps et c'est déjà un peu le cas
l'économie grecque c'est la question de
l'embargorus un embargo qui a été décidé
en représailles en fait des sanctions
européennes après la guerre en Ukraine
jusque là les agriculteurs avaient été
quelque peu épargnés par la crise mais
depuis l'été dernier la situation est
dramatique c'est un reportage de Samia
déchir Hermalle bubilama et Yohan
Loiseau
au pied du mont vermion s'étendent les
vergers du nord de la Grèce dans la
région de Veyrier la culture de la pêche
fait vivre plus de 20000 personnes un
commerce essentiellement tourné vers la
Russie mais depuis août dernier Moscou
interdit l'importation de produits
agroalimentaires européens un embargo
qui risque de mettre l'économie locale à
genoux
on va tailler un peu plus cette année vu
que la grêle a fait des dommages
Constantinos tombe pas cheri travaille
dans les vergers depuis l'âge de 10 ans
il cultivent exclusivement des pêches
l'embargo a débuté le 6 août on était au
pic de la récolte
j'ai subi de lourdes pertes
avec cette histoire j'ai dû sacrifier
50% de ma production pour en faire du
jus
j'en ai aussi envoyé une partie aux
associations caritatives
des distributions gratuites
subventionnées par l'Union européenne
mais pas de quoi couvrir un coup de
production à 30 centimes le kilo
c'est intenable pour un producteur
mais aucun intérêt à cultiver à ce
prix-là
nous emmène à la coopérative agricole de
nahoussa qu'il préside ce mois-ci c'est
la saison des pommes
qui étaient normalement destinés au
marché russe avec la fermeture de ce
marché on a un problème de distribution
on ne sait pas où les vendre
à travers les producteurs c'est toute
l'économie locale que déstabilisent
l'embargo les saisonniers les usines
d'emballage et bien sûr les
transporteurs
la plupart des camions vers la Russie
et les anciens pays du bloc soviétique
en août dernier plus de 3000 camions se
sont retrouvés bloqués à la frontière et
ont dû revenir avec leur cargaison
qui laisse passer ce qui était bloqué
mais ça ne s'est pas fait les camions
ont dû revenir on a perdu beaucoup
d'argent
dans la région l'embargo a mis près de
trois mèches partiel
sincèrement pour ne rien vous cacher je
commence à apprendre une nouvelle langue
étrangère si jamais j'ai besoin de
partir d'ici pour trouver un boulot
oui je suis venu pour tailler mais il
fait froid
ce matin Yanis petit producteur de
pommes reçoit la visite d'un
représentant de Syriza très vite la
discussion s'oriente sur l'embargo
je suis en colère contre l'Union
européenne parce que dans l'intérêt de
certains pays
ils nous ont mis dans une situation sans
rien nous demander
un discours repris par qui accuse
l'Europe d'avoir sacrifié les pays du
Sud le parti promet de tout faire pour
lever l'embargo russe
nous avons promis de quitter le régime
de sanctions l'été dernier quand le
camarade CIPRA s'est venu dans la région
et cette position eu beaucoup des causes
au sein de la population locale c'est
explique la vague de soutien des
agriculteurs pour sirisa parce qu'il
voit ce parti comme finalement le seul
espoir pour régler leurs problèmes
mais pour l'instant l'embargo reste en
vigueur et il promet de faire encore
beaucoup de dégâts en Grèce
Amano la dalle et serre cette tente ta
perte de vue on y cultive des fraises
exportées à 80% en Russie un marché vite
récupéré par les producteurs des pays
voisins
la Turquie a commencé à gagner des parts
de marché d'ailleurs elle a beaucoup de
produits qu'elle peut exporter et la
plupart de ses produits et les exporte
en Russie donc ils ont profité pour les
fraises et pour tous les autres produits
pas de ressentiment pour autant envers
la Turquie c'est bien à l'Union
européenne qu'envole les producteurs
Grecs dans un pays déjà très remonté
contre les Kurdes austérité imposées par
la Troïka
donc dans cette région d'imatis Irisa a
gagné avec près de 34% des voix soit une
progression de 10% depuis les dernières
élections ingress le quand vous voyez
cette situation est-ce qu'on n'a pas
tout fait pour faire détester l'Europe à
ses agriculteurs et plus largement à
tout le peuple grec vous savez cette
situation que vous montrez pour les
producteurs Grecs c'est la situation un
peu partout en Europe c'est rien c'est
rien d'isolement je dois vous dire que
il faut demander ça Poutine c'était son
embargo et c'était une réponse
c'est les banques contre les banques
russes pour les prêts et c'est contre
tout ce qui est matériel pour mener une
guerre
vous voulez qu'on accepte la situation
en Ukraine pour ne pas avoir pour ne pas
subir de des faits négatifs je trouve ça
très irresponsable franchement oui mais
alors là moi je vous demande de répondre
à ces agriculteurs qu'est-ce qu'on fait
pour leur venir en aide vous savez il y
a les fonds européens pour ça les fond
agricole sur là les fonds sont là aussi
pour les producteurs Grecs et autres et
là il faut voir ce qu'on peut faire on a
déjà fait 2000 milliards d'euros pour
ces producteurs là parce qu'on voit leur
situation je suis désolé de le dire
c'est un peu le risque du métier mais
pour les producteurs il faut vraiment
faire quelque chose et là on a fait déjà
quelque chose et on voit tous les jours
ce qu'on peut encore faire parce qu'on
voit leur situation difficile
raviana c'est les risques du métier vous
avez aussi beaucoup de producteurs en
Espagne sauf que bon ça frappe l'Espagne
ça frappe la France ça fera la Pologne
alors je pense que c'est un coup que on
doit accepter vis-à-vis qu'est-ce que ça
passe en ukrainer même que je suis très
critique de la position du Parlement
européen je sais je le trouve trop
militaire ouilatéral de toute façon les
choses les plus importants c'est que la
Russie va changer et stratégiquement
c'est
à dire l'approvisionnement et je pense
que la Chine et des autres vont prendre
les places de l'Espagne
on voit bien que aussi capitaliser sur
ce ras-le-bol de l'Union européenne
alors l'embargorie effectivement s'il a
été décidé pour ces raisons là ne pas
remettre en question ici c'est pas le
propos mais est-ce qu'on les a pas un
petit peu encore abandonné je crois que
la vraie question que ça pose je suis
d'accord avec ce qui est dit là c'est la
question c'est une question d'ordre de
vérité pour l'Europe peut-être bien plus
importantes que la question économique
que la question géostratégique en gros
aujourd'hui on recommence et le prix
dans la tenaille entre les Russes qui
nous disent si vous nous embêtez en
Ukraine on va se tourner vers la Chine
on va se tourner vers l'Asie et en voir
en voir l'Europe et d'un autre côté les
États-Unis qui nous disent un peu la
même chose c'est si vous ne signez pas
aujourd'hui le traité transatlantique on
ira voir l'Asie pour la Chine notamment
pour faire des convergences commerciales
en termes de normes et c'est vrai du
point de vue énergétique je suis
absolument d'accord c'est à dire que
nous sommes trop dépendants aujourd'hui
du point de vue énergétique pour pouvoir
avoir des positions unies sur un certain
nombre de sujets il y a donc là
maintenant une heure de vérité pour
l'Europe est-ce que nous savons être une
grande puissance au niveau international
et ça ça demande d'être autonome du
point de vue commercial ça demande à
être autonome du point de vue
énergétique et ça demande à être en
capacité quand on subit une agression
commerciale comme la Russie nous l'a
fait subir aujourd'hui d'être en
capacité d'y répondre et donc d'aider
ceux qui sont dans la difficulté
aujourd'hui justement il y a un des
agriculteurs de ce reportage qui avait
une interpellation directe je voudrais
qu'on l'écoute
que les pays du Sud ont subi alors
qu'ils dépendent beaucoup de l'économie
agricole est-ce que ça vaut vraiment la
peine de rester dans l'Union européenne
où est la solidarité entre les pays
européens
après tout quand on quand on entend cet
agriculteur est-ce que il y a pas un
petit peu un constat d'échec vous savez
je me suis déjà habituée un peu d'être
le coupable
bien que ça soit très injuste il y a
beaucoup de solidarité beaucoup beaucoup
de solidarité de la part des Allemands
les autres pays aussi ils ont été très
généreux la France a donné 75 milliards
d'euros bien sûr l'Espagne aussi je dois
dire maintenant il y va de tout c'est
pas qu'un seul pays qui peut faire
bouger le monde
c'est que si l'Europe c'est simplement
j'allais dire une coalition de pays qui
est solidaire du point de vue budgétaire
et avec des règles fixes
plus tout ça donc aujourd'hui ce qu'il
faut construire si on veut sauver
l'Union européenne parce que
effectivement autrement tout le monde va
partir au bout d'un moment c'est quoi
et bien tout simplement de dire qu'il
faut harmoniser harmoniser par exemple
fiscalement lutter réellement contre
l'évasion fiscale faire en sorte qu'il y
ait de véritables investissements
communautaire aujourd'hui et pas
simplement le Pendu mon cœur qui a le
mérite d'exister ça veut dire que on a
la responsabilité d'investir là où ça va
mal et pas simplement que quand un état
donne un euro il en attend 5 en retour
donc c'est faire autre chose de l'Europe
que simplement une Europe de contraintes
budgétaire ça ne marche pas c'est pas
les responsabilités du peuple c'est la
responsabilité des politiciens et c'est
pour cette raison que c'est en grec en
Grèce a eu lieu l'arrivée avec des
réponses miraculeuses dans lesquelles on
va être riche et aujourd'hui il y a
demain pourquoi on va pas payer la dette
et cetera et c'est une déclaration
intéressante par les sélections m'a
appris
à la réalité alors toujours trouver le
diable extérieur c'est-à-dire même comme
le grand diable c'est-à-dire nous
parfois on est notre propre diable je
pense qu'il faut qu'il reconnaisse notre
propre responsabilité et ben écoutez ce
sera le mot de la fin merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous d'avoir participé
à ce débat j'espère qu'on aura permis à
noter les spectateurs d'avancer avant de
se quitter je voudrais qu'on regarde
quelques images de la remise du Prix
Louise Weiss du journalisme européen qui
a été remis donc il y a quelques jours
au ministère des Affaires étrangères
donc félicitations à Huguette celle à
agrabie prune Antoine et les étudiants
en journaliste du collège à Strasbourg
qui ont reporté ce prix merci à tous
d'avoir suivi cette émission et on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine ciao à
toutes